so guess what i love sitting on my couch
in my roomy pants and my thick socks
scouring the internet for treasures
and that's why i'm excited we teamed up
with roo
so those are not familiar with rue la la
it's an online store where you can get
high quality designer items at like
insane prices you're going to freak out
lots of people know about this already
so get in the know
so here to rock this segment with me is
my longtime friend solana barfield brown
hi drew
by the way kalana when i first knew you
you were just kalana barfi
i sure was i got married
congratulations i think you did
something three weeks ago that was
pretty important i did i had a whole
baby
[Laughter]
listen even when the world isn't in the
state it's in
a lot of us are doing our online
shopping at home yep
kalana is going to help us run down this
week's hot items on rue la la
and guess what we've rebranded this it's
now drew lala
so lana what do we got first okay so
fall's officially here if you can't tell
about the weather it's changing so it's
time for us to start transitioning to
our
cozier pieces so the first item i have
is just for that
it's a cashmere sweater from a brand the
dumb
and i just love feel how soft it is i
know this is so soft and cozy
this color is called avocado it comes in
seven
different colors seven different colors
and it normally goes for 264 dollars but
today we're getting it at 69
off for 79.99 real cashmere for 79.99
[Applause]
all right so what else have we got okay
i'm really excited about this
dior sunglasses dior gets it right every
season just designing styles that work
for
whether you're edgy or sophisticated no
matter what your face shape is
we have four different styles these
sunglasses normally go for up to
four hundred and eighty dollars we're
getting them at 99.99
that's a discount up to 79 off
hi it's me i'm from the future
all right what's next kalana so i am
obsessing over these bags it's from
ampersand
as apostrophe so they're two tote bags
actually this one
is a tote backpack hybrid oh you got the
sunglasses going
on right now so this is a backpack and
tote
hybrid so it has the straps in the back
for your backpack
or you can hold it with the top handle
as a tote
and the one you have over there is a
sideways tote and it's so roomy
inside there's a pouch and i love it
because
you can use the pouch inside as a little
wallet the quality
of this leather is so amazing the
sideways tote
normally goes for 682 dollars we're
getting it for 279
that's a 58 discount and the backpack
normally goes for 495
we're getting it for 179.99
that's the 63 discount okay
yes so we have these gorgeous layered
necklaces
from rachel reinhardt we're both wearing
them yeah and i love them because
they are really they're like personal
jewelry so it doesn't look too bulky
they're delicate you can layer them with
other pieces you have or you can wear
them alone and it still looks cool and
interesting
see i love that because i always see
that layered look and i just think it
looks so cool and effortless but i know
there's like a whole system that goes
into it right
the key is they have to be the chains
have to be different lengths you know
you look for one that's more like a
choker and then one that's
a little bit longer and this gives you
that effect it's one necklace but it
looks like it's two
so the necklace normally goes for 200
we're getting it at 79.99
that's a 60 off discount everybody's
priority of how they spend their money
should be fun not judged personal
and who knows what people are going to
gravitate towards
right and we're just here to show the
magic of rue la la and what
an amazing price point that you can get
like this very luxe designer stuff for
right and all the great options kalana
would you please do me the favor
of standing up because i just
need to comment on your head to toe look
i mean you have a black and white
threaded skirt yes
you have like icicle
strappy like shoes yes you have a tie
belted jacket you are so
cool thank you drew and getting like
advice and tips on how to do this all
from you ladies and gentlemen
like look at the authority kalana
barfield brown okay
thank you drew thank you so much
until we meet again darling
this has been drew la la and for all of
you
at home you can find these items at the
real rue la la
dot com slash the drew barrymore show
and remember these deals are only
available
while supplies last